I guess
[Applause]
baby
Kelsey ballerini is telling her side of
the story the best way she knows how
through music the country singer dropped
a surprise EP on Valentine's Day
complete with six new songs and a short
film titled rolling up the welcome mat
[Music]
the singer co-wrote every song on the EP
and also co-wrote and directed the short
film all of which hint at the details of
her divorce to fellow country singer
Morgan Evans
[Music]
on the papers Kelsey shared a snippet of
the film on her Instagram with the
caption here's my healing Journey here's
my heart here's my truth I've never been
this open I've never been this bold and
I've never been this proud of my Arts so
with love and respect I'm rolling up the
welcome mats
it's all the way that I carry yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
each song seems to shed a light on
different factors leading to Kelsey and
Morgan's divorce with blindsided
appearing to a dress that her ex-husband
wanted a family while she did not
it wasn't hard to find baby
[Music]
the surprise drop comes just a few
months after Morgan Evans released his
own breakup Anthem over for you where
the singer confesses his heartbreak over
the situation
[Music]
Kelsey does share another message in her
new music that through all the ups and
downs she wishes her ex the best
I hope when I see you there you smile
I hope that you find somebody new
I hope that you get the house and The
Good Wife and the kids
and I hope I never leave me again